hey leute was glaubt willkommen beim
neuen video
bevor wir anfangen ich wollte ich
eigentlich noch wie ein forscher also
wir wollten das video zu zweit machen
aber irgendwie wollte schon längst da
was hier passiert ist man kennt wo ich
bin vor einer freundin gekommen und dann
bin ich auf der autobahn und ich sage
heute sind nur solche verlinken auf auto
unterwegs
ich bin ein fan denkt - oh ja okay ich
mache jetzt kurze pause wenn du raus so
auf so einem parkplatz auf einmal hält
einfach so eine ältere frau mia und ich
musste runter auf den graben und dann
bin ich so lead for speed nicht die
beste so an der wand hoch sei wirklich
übertrieben aber mein herz ist
stehengeblieben michalek das heute ist
wenig so viel passiert erst verpassten
unfall gemacht zu hause aber keiner da
ist es egal ob du bist jetzt hier bei
uns waren wir uns für euch heute ein
ganz spezielles thema 1 verlassen
worüber wir einfach mal so unsere
ansichten mit euch teilen wollten und
zwar was ist heute das thema heute also
das heutige thema ist wie man eine [ __ ]
erkennt niveaulos es gibt ja richtig
viele klischees nennen so wie zum
beispiel so zb ausschnitte bis zum
bauchnabel die hose bis zum hals auf
zaubern sie teilt oder make up das waren
damit eigentlich noch mein ganzes zimmer
neu anmalen kann aber diese ganzen
klischees unserer meinung so dass sagt
vielleicht ein bisschen aus aber längst
sich alles so die meisten vertuschen
dass ihr ja auf jeden fall also ich habe
meine erfahrungen so gemacht und halt
auch im umkreis gehört das zum beispiel
die meisten matches sarah knappik ist
gar niveaulos alter gibt es eigentlich
auch einen netten ausflug für so was
google braten bordsteinschwalbe
ist weil ist sehen wir so erkennst du
einen bordstein
also ich habe den eindruck dass diese
ganzen bordstein schwach hilfen was ich
also ich habe den eindruck dass die
meisten bordstein schaden
meistens gar nicht erkannt werden und
dass die eigentlich meistens immer so
undercover unterwegs sind ich persönlich
glaube so eine bordsteinschwalbe
entwickelt sich meistens dadurch dass
ein mädchen meistens davor eine
beziehung hatte die zum beispiel drei
jahre zwei jahre vier jahre lang ging
und dann sozusagen irgendwann mal eine
single ist und die und die entwickelt
sich halt so dass wir halt sehr lange
immer denselben typ hatte und in
kommerziell wenig andere interessen und
möchte andere leute kennenlernen und
weißt du so kommt es am meisten ach so
ja dann wurde ihr herz gebrochen weil ja
dann nicht mehr zusammen sehr genau und
dann denkt sich so ein mädchen oder ein
junge halt vielleicht auch so boah ist
das ein arschloch ich jetzt eigentlich
sehr gewinnen und dann wird sie halt so
sie ist praktisch in die beziehung
gekommen mit 15 hatte dann schluss mit
17 an herz gebrochen 54 56
so kurz vorm 18 lebensjahre und dann
geht's ab weil mit einem zu langen ball
rein überall raus und ab geht die maus
kennst du diese was heißt kennst du also
man hört das so ich will jetzt auch
nichts falsches sagen ja kein schlechtes
vorbild sein für meine zu dion und zwar
diese bordstein schreiben die schreiben
dann ihren partner am nächsten tag oder
so am nächsten morgen so sorry da nur
ich war ein ausnahmezustand das war ich
bin eigentlich nicht so ich hab was
getrunken
eigentlich bin ich keine
bordsteinschwalbe alex ich sag dir eine
sache
diese ausrede das ist die 08 15 ausrede
die ich überall schon gehört 15 ausrede
der golf stand spalier ach ja und
komischerweise war es ja auch beim
besten freund jetzt noch eine ausnahme
naja irgendwie jede woche so nah sie ist
halt durchgehend unterwegs im
ausnahmezustand also dann gibt auch noch
mal diese bordsteinschwalben die zum
beispiel so ausgesehen
dieses wasser techniker frühere nicht
nur wer gut ist hat geklappt es war aber
nicht auf der kamera eine kurze neben
anekdote alles und ich hab früher
fußball zusammen gespielt aber weiß das
schlimmste sind immer noch diese insta
bordsteinschwalben so oder keine ahnung
facebook bordsteinschwalbe deshalb offen
zugeben dass sie eine bordsteinschwalbe
sind und tagtäglich auch im
bordsteinschwalben koop modus unterwegs
sind ja das wollen auch stolz darauf ich
kann man schon so ein paar namen die ich
im kopf habe vorsagen von insta
bordsteinschwalben okay manchmal also
eine heißt zum beispiel ultra
bordsteinschwalbe die anreise oder zum
beispiel wegs xx wahrscheinlich weil wir
xxx aber weißt du was jetzt auch
wirklich noch mal sagen muss es gibt ja
auch männliche wollstein schwellen oder
wöchentlich zu jetzt mal ein beispiel so
eine eine bordsteinschwalbe also die
victor bordsteinschwalbe genannt wird
auch eigentlich zu recht so hast du in
einem monat was mit zehn verschiedenen
und wenn dann eine mensch eigentlich
auch bordsteinschwalbe in einem monat
was mit zehn verschiedenen hat dann an
er warte ich das ehrlich so bei jüngste
frauen werden dafür geerntet wenn sie
mit zehn männern um machen und wenn man
was mit zehn mann hat dann ist ja der
übliche kind wieso ist es eigentlich so
du da bin ich überfragt tatsächlich
firma glock deutschland ja heute werden
euch dieses video gefallen hat und ihr
auch wirklich so diese
bordsteinschwalben überhaupt nicht
abkönnen sich jetzt männlich oder
weiblich könnt ihr gerne doch nach oben
da lassen
des weiteren muss ich auch sagen wir
haben es hier auf seinem channel der das
ganze video beschreibung verlinkt auch
ein video gemacht schaut auf jeden fall
vorbei lassen aber bei ihm da wie viel
arbeit als 2000 1600 mittlerweile 600
ich würde sagen 34 5000 schaffen wir
locker deswegen geht auf seinen kasten
aber da wird mich auch persönlich sehr
freuen uns dass rachel weisz eingewendet
wir sehen uns am sonntag wieder
reingeschaut entscheiden